sleep is chapter six
of of our forthcoming book as i said at
the top of the hour
and um it's going to be a short excerpt
today just two pages
uh from the middle of the chapter so in
the beginning of the chapter we walk
through a little bit about what sleep is
and whether or not we think
um aliens if they landed on the planet
would recognize what we do for
a third of our lives i'm not going to
give that away i'm just going to jump
right into the section
called dreams and hallucinations
you'll remember this moment in the
darkest quietest moment of some night
long ago
hours after we had both been asleep
heather sat up looked at brett and said
do you seriously intend to leave these
car parts on the bed
brett's answer i think so yes did not
ease tensions any
furthermore the fact that there were of
course no car parts anywhere near the
bed would not be admitted as evidence in
this discussion
it wasn't the first time that heather
had said something while deeply asleep
that was impossible to engage using the
normal rules
when brett responded to heather's sleep
talk the tone generally decayed quickly
there was it seemed no reasoning with
either of us without having any
consciousness of these episodes heather
somehow knew
later when awake and being told about
them what brett was supposed to do
don't engage me let me have both sides
of the conversation it will be over soon
enough
seeing things that aren't there hearing
sounds that were never made believing
things that are not true yet being
certain of them
being unable to control one's movements
having conversations with people who
don't exist
as it turns out a list of symptoms of a
person with schizophrenia has a
suspicious overlap with a person asleep
and dreaming
all of us enter this state every night
even though not everyone reaches out
through that state and talks in their
sleep
we do not regularly draw this parallel
because our dream state usually comes
with paralysis and amnesia
any confrontations with reality are
blissfully hidden from us by the time we
get to our morning coffee
how surprising then that organisms that
do not appear to have had our best
interests in mind
such as psilocybe mushrooms and peyote
cactus seem to have accessed these very
same tendencies to explain this we need
to take a step back
organisms including us and other animals
plus plants and fungi
do not generally want to be eaten fruit
nectar and milk are as we discussed in
the previous chapter
exceptions to this rule but in general
organisms put a lot of work into
discouraging the consumption of their
body parts
structural barriers are one method
cactus spines porcupine coils turtle
shells
another is poison but it is often too
crude to be maximally effective
if a deer dies after eating foxglove the
deer will be replaced by another deer
that knows nothing of the plant's poison
on the other hand if a deer expands its
dietary repertoire to include psilocybe
mushrooms and spends the rest of the day
having a temporary psychotic break
it would may well look elsewhere for its
next meal having been educated and
perhaps terrorized
rather than killed secondary compound is
a loosely defined botanical term for a
substance that is not functional within
the organism that produces it
rather it is intended to interact with
pathways and other creatures often in a
hostile way
the irritants in poison ivy are an
obvious deterrent to herbivores eating
those leaves
similarly potatoes in the other
nightshades contain endogenous
pesticides a class of compounds known as
glycoalkaloids that are highly toxic to
humans
in contrast to those pure poisons and
irritants consider these secondary
compounds
capsaicin the molecule that creates the
burning sensation when we eat chili
peppers
generally dissuades mammals from eating
seeds that are intended for birds which
do not have the receptors to sense the
heat
and caffeine which disincentivizes
herbivores from eating caffeinated seeds
at high concentrations
may also be a kind of pharmacological
social engineering on the part of the
plants
when bees are given sugar rewards that
contain caffeine
their spatial memory improve improves
threefold
the caffeinated nectar of both citrus
and coffee flowers
may well be priming their pollinators
the bees to remember them and to come
back for more
from suicide mushrooms and ergot fungi
to peyote cactus and the botanical brew
in ayahuasca
to salvia and sonoran desert toads there
are fungi plants and animals that
produce secondary compounds that
interact
with our physiology in ways that mirror
dream states
call them hallucinogens or psychedelics
or entheogens their effect on us can be
narrative and elucidating
we live our days connected by dreams
lest we wake up each morning imagining
that we are brand new beings our dreams
give us context and allow us to grow
between days
we are conscious during the day and
unconscious in the first part of the
night during non-rem sleep
once rem picks up in the second half of
each night our consciousness is borrowed
our bodies taken safely offline
paralyzed and our conscious minds create
fiction strange
hypothetical and extravagant sometimes
they're even true a vast arrays of cult
a vast array of cultures have some
tradition in which hallucinogenic states
are intentionally triggered and some are
all of their members
humans being human it is not surprising
to find that many cultures have borrowed
secondary compounds that trigger
terrifying waking dreams
and have turned what might have been a
bad trip into an important tool for
human consciousness expansion
more on this in chapter 12. just as many
cultures have appropriated the
hallucinogenic secondary compounds of
plants and fungus to expand the
consciousness of their members
many also have sleep rituals from the
simple to the elaborate by which
individuals prepare for their nightly
slumbers
even some of our closest relatives
engage in rituals in advance of sleep
and the next section tells of us
discovering some in some
spider monkeys in guatemala
pretty exciting i'm actually quite
interested to hear
uh what the world will make of this set
of hypotheses
when it engages them it's uh it's
something i've long wanted to bring into
the world and i guess we're finally
going to find out
whether uh um whether people are ready
for it
but uh um anyway uh
well where do you what do you think we
should talk about here yeah i mean
there's there's a lot to say
yeah there's a lot to say actually zach
did you just get an email from me i
wanted to show this uh
years after we started talking about um
these hypotheses
uh i ran into this cartoon it's an xkcd
cartoon um you'll have to make a bit
bigger i think for most people
people including people on mobile who
might want to see it
um so it starts out with a
a guy he's just awakened from a dream
their people repelling from
zeppelin there's a nuclear explosion
going on near
a major city
he runs down the stairs
he goes to the breakfast table to talk
to his significant other as the whole
thing evaporates and he's left with
almost nothing you could possibly
describe and she appears to be
nonplussed
right and the uh hidden caption uh to
the thing is
every damn morning that's the title
actually oh it's every day morning yeah
um anyway so yes this idea that our
dreams are actually
um built to be hidden
from our conscious minds in a certain
way and then
you know it wasn't in the piece that you
read but
the fact that some dreams aren't so
dreams aren't what
aren't deliberate or are not adaptively
hidden
there seem to be some dreams that just
have their message right there
emblazoned
on them is that what you mean well what
i mean is there's a difference between
the dream that you can't remember
and the dream that you can struggle to
remember something of and the dream
that to my way of thinking is actually
handed across the consciousness barrier
because its purpose is actually for your
consciousness to see it which feel very
different and i think these are all
disrupted by
our terrible relationship with alarm
clocks which basically interrupt our
dream cycles arbitrarily
alarm clocks and other intrusions in the
soundscape
and also light and we'll talk a little
bit about light here but yeah
right yeah but for those of us um who
sometimes have the experience of solving
a difficult problem
in our sleep right it's very often one
of these things where you awake with a
solution that you're keenly aware of
well and so i mean you you say that
speaking specifically of mental or
intellectual problems right
um i think i think probably everyone has
everyone has solved problems in their
sleep whether or not they recognize it
as such so there are you know there are
physical problems that can be solved if
you're like a craftsman if you're trying
to figure out how to you know make a
particular joint or something
um but also the one that is probably the
most ubiquitous and perhaps the most
ancient of at least
these types that we've sort of
categorized here um
are just you know how how to get your
body to do a thing
and in the modern world that might be
you know skateboarding or
rock climbing or forehand frisbee or you
know whatever it is
but you know you work at it you work out
you work at it at some point you get you
know you either walk away
calm or not um and um
the next time you try it if you have had
time to sleep between now and then
you're almost always better at it
right and the the distinction yeah i
mean
as people who know the podcast well or
people who uh
will read in the book obviously all
that dream stuff has to pay its way
right not every dream does but on
average it all has to pay its way
because it's very expensive
um so the question is so expense it's
metabolically expensive because the
brain
is uh by far the most expensive organ to
run in the body and when it's doing all
this extra stuff
even if it's got body offline actually
muscle muscles are cheaper to run
um in in aggregate than the brain is
yeah the brain is just
a super expensive run you can also you
know
you can dormantize it and so choosing to
make it active
about narratives that aren't real and on
all of that is something adaptation has
done to us for a reason
what the reason isn't so obvious but
that there's a reason or that there has
to be
is clear enough but the point is
yes we have all probably most of what we
do in dreams is at least attempt to
solve problems and
we will all have solved problems and in
general those dreams that you can't
remember are presumably about solving
uh problems that you uh you know at some
level that is not conscious
um but yeah the dreams i was talking
about the ones that seem to get handed
across the consciousness barrier
are ones you know in my experience it's
been like there's some
object that you're trying to fix and you
can't figure out
why it's not working and then you wake
up with the solution to it
it's clear that that work was done by
your sleeping self
but it's also clear that your your
unconscious mind isn't in a position to
operationalize it
right yeah so it's yeah it's a pretty
fascinating
i do still wonder about those car parts
though
um yes well i mean you know i i hadn't
thought
through but yeah i mean they had to go
somewhere i guess
yeah you do always threaten to store
things on my side of the bed since that
incident
yeah is that just me
[Laughter]
no one else threatens to store things on
my side of the bed right no i just
thought it was symmetrical i thought you
know i
i do threaten to start new objects that
have no place
i think if i do that it's following your
lead oh is that right yes
oh god yes i've created a monster yeah
yeah no i want to store things on my
side of the bed yeah apparently
um okay more more
from this or um i mean i don't know i'm
i'm
i'm pretty happy with it but all right
uh let us
then so i'm just going to read as we
mentioned last week
most of the chapters in the book have at
the very end um
the corrective lens um and so just the
last corrective lens from the sleep
chapter is this
this advice that we are giving most of
these are at the individual level this
is one for the societal level
restrict outdoor blue spectrum light at
the societal level particularly lights
that shine upward and outward at all
hours of the night
nighttime darkness is healthy 24 hour
light is not
and is even implicated in higher rates
of disease furthermore humans deserve a
night sky
a sky full of possibilities sometimes of
clouds often the moon
occasionally planets nearly always stars
in the milky way in which we live
besides sleep which we need what else
might we lose when we disappear our own
night sky and we don't know the answer
to that
right we will lose we potentially lose a
lot
and in light of that in light of that
there's a review paper out this year um
called non-visual effects of indoor
light environment on humans a review so
this isn't this is
very very restrictive you know it's not
about visual effects it's not about the
effects of outdoor stuff
um but it's a review of the
extant evidence which concludes a few
things
and really they aren't going to be
surprising but um
but it's it's all nicely in in this one
paper now
they find um from the review of the
literature that at night
uh well that first of all let me just
define a few terms they've got
illuminance
as one of their terms which is just um i
mean it's just basically brightness
luminous flux per unit as measured in
either foot candles or lux
so illuminance and then cct which is the
correlated color temperature
which is basically a measure of um
temperature which is to say the higher
cct the bluer and cooler
the light is and the lower the cct the
warmer and yellower the light is
and so in advance of us going through
the evidence
um daytime light tends to be blue and
um end of day and fire lights tend to be
you know warmer cct
lower cct and yellower redder
okay so at night both high illuminance
brighter and high cct that is cooler
bluer light
are positively correlated with the
suppression of melatonin
which i think many of us knew that but
there is there's basically nothing going
in the opposite direction there
furthermore exposure to both blue light
and high cct light
basically the same thing not quite you
know different researchers using
slightly different standards and
measures at night exposure to blue
knight blue light and cool light at
night
induce a delayed phase shift which is
also consistent with
a reduction in melatonin
um basically your sleep is going to be
disrupted
um you know but it's not you know
in in almost none of these cases can you
just say ah you know high cct light bad
blue light bad no you know during the
day especially in the mornings
the more exposed we are to blue light um
and i think i mentioned this last week
although maybe
i failed to but there's a different
piece of research that shows that
the earlier in the mornings you tend to
be exposed
to bright light to outdoor light to
cooler light um
that correlates with lower bmi like you
know
obesity tends not to to to thrive as
well among people
who are getting out into bright outdoor
light early in the mornings
so high cct again the bluer light
stimulates positive mood
and high illuminance during the daytime
is positively correlated with subjective
alertness so you know you're more awake
there's also a bunch of mood stuff the
mood stuff is a little
dicier so i didn't include it here and
then one of the papers that they cite
from 2013 is
that after you know after millennia
maybe more than millennia
of sort of folk folk tales and
cultural stories about the moon
influencing
um influencing all sorts of things
influencing mood and fertility and
behavior
and you know all of these things there's
a paper from 2013
that finds that the lunar cycle does
indeed influence human sleep
and they actually did this um they went
and collected data
that had been collected from a sleep lab
so afterwards people who actually aren't
even affected by the light from the moon
it's actually in the
like with they've picked up enough
information about what the
lunar cycle is that even while the moon
is not impacting them directly it's
still affecting their sleep
yeah so what they have is um
uh and suff electroencephalogram
delta activity during nrem sleep so eeg
delta activity during non-rem sleep
which is an indicator of deep sleep
decreases by 30
during the full moon time to fall asleep
increases by five minutes not a lot um
but the eeg assessed total sleep
duration is also reduced by 20 minutes
during the full moon without you know
for people who were sleeping
inside in a sleep lab without any you
know
without this being on the table about
something that they were being
asked to think about it's interesting
because people are so disconnected from
the lunar cycle now that it's hard for
me to
you know that's some signal is so strong
that it's getting through the fact that
if you ask most people on most
days where we are in the lunar cycle
they have no idea right and
um i mean i think this is this is
beautiful because it's uh it's a full
moon right now
today is the full moon and uh it's you
know especially in the northern summer
at least in
in the part of the world where we live
we're going to have a clear blue sky and
i was i was
lucky enough to be out on the water very
early this morning um
and you know bright bright blue
illuminance you know high high
illuminance bright
high cct light early in the morning and
then to be able to go back out at night
and see
the full moon rising and um
yeah it's going to take a little longer
to fall asleep maybe for you know for
for the whole planet during during a
full moon according to this research
and your sleep duration is going to be
reduced by a bit and
what what this paper didn't try to look
at um but what i predict is true
is that there are also going to be
seasonal differences right and so
you know whereas we have these
expectations in modern and you're in
weird countries
that you know you start work at eight or
you you go to class at eight
and that happens you know the farther
away from the equator you are the less
sense that makes physiologically
um across the entire year you know 8 a.m
here in in september when classes start
um it's very very bright out and in
december it's still dark out
and you know being expected to to get up
with the same enthusiasm and alertness
and ability to do calculus or whatever
it is
you know you're going to uh if you've
been
you've been raised in part by the
photons from the sun
as opposed to by you know your mom
telling you have to get out of bed
and uh and your alarm clock uh of course
you're not going to be equally capable
of course not yeah in in some sense
um i think i think we made the point uh
on dark horse
several weeks ago that there is a
distinction between biological time
and laboratory time and it's not that
laboratory time
doesn't exist it's not that somebody
made it up right
laboratory time exists and you can
measure it but the idea
that what we're going to do is build
mechanical clocks
and and uh align ourselves with them
align our behavior with them
that's not how it works and you know as
soon as you
break your cycle just you know even
somebody who lives by
clocks if you go backpacking right
suddenly you find yourself not so eager
to stay up to 11
right you know it's like oh the sun sets
unless it's
late june and you're on vancouver island
right right if you're very far north
yeah but the point is you know
you tend to get up very easily you don't
need an alarm clock in the morning and
you don't need somebody to tell you hey
it's getting really late you need to go
to bed because
it just it resets very very quickly um
now
you know the problem is it trades off
two things your
your personal cycle and how it
interfaces with
uh you know the the uh celestial
motions of various objects
is at odds with your ability to say i
will meet you at this place at that time
right or we will engage in this activity
in this location
you know on this day and this time we
have to be able to do that because
that's the way civilization
works but to imagine that we are not
borrowing from
a much more natural intuitive and
ancient
interaction with time is is just it's an
error
yeah and you know you see you
begin to see in a way that i don't feel
like i was seeing signage at parks and
such
in the 70s and 80s when we were growing
up um you know some places now say open
you know dawn to dusk this sort of thing
um but then i was at a i was at a park i
hadn't been at
um before last week and
it was it was weird it was like open 8
a.m through dusk
it's like why and i was you know i again
was showing up to some new place to
paddle board on some new river
um and i was there at seven and it was
it had been the sun had risen an hour
and a half earlier and i was there an
hour before the park opened i just
thought you know why
like what what's to what end is this
park
closed uh until 8 a.m even though
it being open 8 a.m in the winter you
know to the degree that it's about
safety
and and you know not being policed um
when it's dark out
well you know just just make it dawn to
dusk then
yeah i mean i agree with you that that's
you know the good thing about a don and
dusk rule is that
you can operationalize it because
everybody can figure out whether it's
you know after dawn or past dusk
um the problem is probably
an enforcement issue unfortunately right
but in this particular case
they had one end that was a clock a you
know
a lab time in your formulation and one
that was an astronomical time
and um yeah i just it seemed it seemed a
little random
to choose one you know one is a lab time
and one is an astronomical time yeah
yeah but you're also right that as you
get closer to the equator
these things become you know if you're
really close to the equator they become
so
regular that you actually um do it six
to six you know like that's
right and exactly and it doesn't it
doesn't wobble
at the equator but um the farther north
or south you are the farther away from
the equator you are the more variation
it's going to be and
like i said i think um you know now we
have we have good evidence and i presume
that that evidence will grow
that the lunar cycle is actually
affecting our sleep um
we know that and it's you know it's not
just um
you know female typical sex hormones
that are cert that are that are changing
with you know along cycles that are the
same length of time as the lunar cycle
and that's no accident it's you know
there are a lot of our hormones for both
of us both of us
all of us are both sexes is what i meant
right um that that are that are cyclic
and
um it's it's going to be circadian it's
going to be lunar and it's going to be
seasonal as well and the seasonal stuff
will be you know there will be higher
peaks and lower lows
uh the farther from the equator you're
going to be totally um
i'm also uh always uh
keen to point out that in other
creatures
there are much less cryptic reasons for
these things
um so uh lunar phobia in bats being
a great example um if you go out and you
try to catch
bats you find that typically you get
many fewer bats
when you do so uh you know the fuller
the moon the fewer the bats
and the reason for this is typically
interpreted as um
basically increased vulnerability to
visual predators especially owls
um so the idea is the the
you know bats are nocturnal presumably
mostly because it hides them from their
predators
um and microbats at least have a
mechanism for navigating at night
that allows them not to be hobbled by it
so echolocation works very well at night
um there are some bats that navigate uh
visually and they have giant eyes but
in any case for most bats the advantage
of hunting at night is
diminished when their predators have
a fair number of photons to go on and so
anyway
you get this lunar phobia effect
obviously human beings are not
likely to be sensitive for that reason
but the fact that we
remain sensitive is pretty pretty
interesting
well i wouldn't be surprised if there
weren't
in different cultures some restrictions
on
when particular types of hunts take
place regarding the moon
well you know both both because the moon
makes it easier to hunt and easier to be
hunted it's very rare for humans to hunt
at night my guess would be so there
obviously
are creatures that will lead people but
they're also
uh typically typically cultural
responses
right like the mythology that says you
know if a lion
has hunted a person that you have to
kill that lion because it has developed
a taste for
human blood or whatever and these things
function presumably very effectively to
select
against the animals that experiment with
the hunting of
people and so anyway
you know you and i have run into
crocodiles that could easily kill a
person that
you know flee sure in fear when we swim
near them
um and you know obviously mountain lions
are fully capable of killing a person
but they very rarely do
so but they're you know they're famously
and i don't remember which uh which
fossils but
you know they're famously these you know
african fossils with the
with the canine holes from some large
cat in their heads having been you know
having had some hominid some early
homing that have been dragged up a tree
right i don't i don't actually remember
you know most most cats are diurnal
i think that was an australopithecine
and a leopard
um most cats aren't diurnal but i think
i think that was imagined to be yes a
leopard which
you know they're kind of crepuscular
they yeah i don't know yeah yeah
that was the case actually no they've
got the the cats have all the cats have
topedum lucidum
so um so they are they are presumably
better able to navigate at night than we
are
right but which is this reflection
sufficiently early human ancestor
that it's they were unlikely to have
mythology around you know the
killing of animals that have killed
people so anyway
the question at least the hypothesis on
the table is that mythologies
that um force people to kill
animals that have killed their kin
actually function to select
against that that they create a
superstition or something equivalent to
it
in the wild animals that reduces the
hunting of people
[Music]